the movie opens up in a tense setting
four of the most intelligent people in
the country are locked inside a small
room they are then given incredibly
tough mathematical questions with one
minute to solve each of them failing to
do so will result in the room slowly
shrinking by the second if the group
fails to answer the question for an
extended period of time they will be
crushed to death quick man what's two
plus two I don't know I don't know
following this the movie Cuts back to
some weeks earlier a handsome guy is
seen captivating a group of women with
not his looks but a discussion on the
gold Bock conjecture this movie was not
based on a true story goldbach
conjecture is actually one of the oldest
unsolved problems in the history of
mathematics it turns out the handsome
guys managed to solve the near
impossible problem and is now planning
to demonstrate it to the public right
then his friend yells at him and asks
him to hurry to his room unfortunately
when the handsome guy enters his room he
discovers that someone has destroyed his
presentation on the goldbach conjecture
this deeply upsets him as now he has to
redo the entire thing in such a short
period of time the scene then shifts to
an old man and mathematician playing
chess with a friend at the same moment
he shares a letter he received from a
stranger named fermat with his friend
the letter invites the country's top
mathematicians to solve a challenging
puzzle within 10 days and the old man
seems very happy to attend elsewhere we
see a beard man struggling to solve the
same problem in a library as he is
trying his best to find a clue the
librarian approaches him and reminds him
to put the books back alphabetically
after this when the bearded man looks at
the problem again he realizes that the
solution to the puzzle is also
alphabetical Overjoyed he solves the
puzzle just in time
ABCD I did it following their successful
solution of the mathematical puzzle the
participants receive a second letter
from fermat the letter reveals that only
four individuals manage to solve the
puzzle and for that they are being
officially invited to solve the greatest
mathematical Enigma in their country the
letter also includes instructions
regarding the meeting place and a
restriction on the use of cellular
phones to maintain anonymity the
participants are given aliases named
after well-known academicians I think
it's academics they will go by the names
dork nerd wiener and Pie as instructed
the four individuals meet at a riverbank
wearing their designated nicknames on
their clothes Pascal for the bearded man
galwa for the attractive young man
Hilbert for the elderly gentleman and
Oliva for the only woman among them at
dusk a car from the other side of the
river flashes its headlights signaling
to the participants the group then
realizes that they need to cross the
river using a boat found on the bank
they cross the river and reached the car
which appears to be empty however they
discover a personal digital assistant
PDA that also stands for public drunk
affection but these guys don't know
about that connected to the car's GPS
system containing information about
their destination the four individuals
then get into the car and with the help
of the GPS arrive at an abandoned
warehouse in the countryside inside the
warehouse they find an elegant room
where they begin to explore and wait for
their host fermat to arrive right then
galwa reveals that before they arrived
there he tried to dig deeper into
Fermat's real identity but failed to
find any information while he is talking
an old man enters the room and claims to
be format the group then eagerly
socializes with format over for dinner
discussing Academia mathematics puzzles
and riddles also virginity however their
evening takes a sudden turn when fermat
receives a phone call from a hospital
regarding the condition of his comatose
daughter fermat immediately gets nervous
and tells the group that he needs to go
to the hospital he then leaves but not
before promising the group that he will
be back within an hour as firmat rushes
off he unintentionally leaves his coat
behind Pascal tries to catch up to him
to return the coat but fails as he
returns to the room carrying Fermat's
coat he discovers a wallet inside it
containing a photo of a young woman
Pascal is taken aback to see the photo
as if he is related to her meanwhile
Hilbert exits briefly to wash his hands
and inadvertently catches Olivia and
galwa in a compromising position he
watches them kissing for a while and
re-enters the room where Pascal shows
them Fermat's forgotten coat galwa
searches the pockets and finds some ID
cards revealing Fermat's real name Roman
just then a mathematical puzzle with a
one minute time limit appears on the PDA
and the group scrambles to solve it
before time runs out while Pascal
examines the walls Olivia Hilbert and
galwa work together to crack the puzzle
however they failed to complete the
puzzle in the given time and Pascal
realizes that the walls around the room
are moving he tells the same to the
others and this creates a panic
situation fortunately before they are
crushed to death Pascal digs deep and
eventually solves the puzzle and as soon
as they enter the correct answer in the
PDA the walls stop moving this makes the
group breathe a cyber Leaf but little
did they know that they are in for a
torrid turn of events soon another
Enigma pops up on the PDA this one
contains a series of ones and zeros and
Hilbert proceeds to solve it with the
help of playing blocks kept there at
this time Pascal looks around the room
and finds some documentation papers
revealing that the four walls of the
room are connected to each of the
powerful hydraulic presses and to the
PDA except for Pascal the trio tries
their best to stop the moving walls by
shoving books and shelves into them but
none of it seems to work books won't
solve all your problems you friggin
nerds amidst the chaos Pascal confesses
to accidentally running over Fermat's
daughter a month ago revealing that this
is his revenge but the others are unsure
about why they have been dragged into
this then galwa finally solves the
problem but just seconds later another
one arises when the room begins to
shrink again the light from one corner
breaks luckily the three men quickly
saved the remaining lights while Olivia
solves the puzzle causing the room to
stop shrinking as they catch their
breath the players reveal information
about themselves hoping to find a
connection and an answer as to why
fermat chose them over all other
participants Pascal reveals that the
academics from their Alias died at the
same age they are now catching
everyone's attention he then shows them
the books written by famous
mathematicians with the same name and
concludes that they are here to die just
then the cell phone shines again and
another puzzle arises this time when
Olivia focuses on solving the puzzle on
her own the other three play the
bookshelf and the other furniture on the
floor trying to stop the movement of the
walls though Olivia solves the Enigma
with some time remaining galwa suggests
that she not submit the answer as
another will appear immediately he
instead asks her to help them arrange
the furniture during this galwa tosses a
table to stop the Moving Wall without
noticing the PDA that was kept on top of
it suddenly when the time is up the
walls starts shrinking and the group
fails to find the PDA to enter the
answer to the previous Enigma in the
midst of the search galwa stumbles upon
an invitation to format this makes the
group wonder why the host would invite
himself to his own game they deduced
that this format is a fake one but they
don't have much time to ponder as they
need to find the phone fortunately
Olivia finds it in the nick of time and
Hilbert inputs the correct answer
causing the room to stop shrinking
meanwhile the fake fermat they had
encountered before becomes agitated and
argues with hospital staff about a phone
call he had received however the staff
informs him that the hospital had not
called him and upon checking his call on
they discover a private number it is
then revealed that the real format who
invited the force Scholars is still
unknown in the fake format they had met
earlier is just another player in the
game the true host has used him to
deceive the others and the fake ferment
has no idea about this as the nursery
assures the fake fermat about his
daughter's stable condition the tense
situation defuses meanwhile back at the
Players Olivia and galwa have a
disagreement about the person who
destroyed the latter's presentation
Olivia suspects that the real format
might be responsible but galwa believes
that it was some random kid as they
argue Hill Barrett notices that Olivia
seems to know galwa well and pushes her
to reveal their past relationship
seemingly trapped she finally confesses
that they used to date but their
relationship ended when galwa accused
her of cheating here they were just
pretending to not know each other so as
to not arouse any unwanted attention
soon their conversation is interrupted
when Pascal reads another puzzle from
the phone the players then shift their
focus to solving the problem but
unfortunately time runs out before they
can complete it the walls start moving
again but the players remain composed
and determined just seconds later they
solved the puzzle and move on to the
next Enigma this time Hilbert insists on
solving it while Olivia starts
explaining her side of the story she
admits to playing a game of chess online
but when she was defeated by a skilled
opponent her curiosity turned into
interest she then reveals that she
attended a gathering of important people
on a boat after getting an invitation
from the mysterious player after
discovering some illegal activities
happening on the boat the sense of
freedom and excitement Drew Olivia back
to the party time in time again I read
that terribly this caused galwa to
suspect her of having an affair she was
having an affair with fun after
listening to this Pascal deduces that
the person Olivia Matt might have
planned and organized everything to
everyone's surprise Olivia denies this
and reveals that the person who invited
her is actually in the room with them
Pascal then turns to hellbert who seems
to be ignoring the situation while galwa
clenches jaw and fist in frustration
enraged he tries to break the PDA while
Olivia silently cries remembering her
awful Deeds Pascal screams at galwa
warning him that their lives depend on
the PDA but the handsome guy no longer
seems to care about it suddenly the
walls start to move again and Pascal
realizes that the person who made the
phone call to the fake ferment must have
been behind everything he thinks for a
while and deduces that galwa could not
have made the call while sitting in
front of them and the only person who is
not present during the call was Hilbert
to everyone's surprise Hilbert calmly
admits that he is the real format Pascal
then checks his suitcase and finds out
that he is the one who had sent the
letters to them scared Olivia instructs
Pascal to call the fake ferment for help
but hellbert reveals that he is already
dead Hilbert also mentions that he had
placed a poisonous chemical inside the
fake Fermat's car that can kill him
within minutes why even invite him at
all then meanwhile a police officer
stops the fake ferment for inattentive
driving as he tries to answer his phone
the two chat for a while and when the
old man mentions his sick daughter the
officer feels pity on him and lets him
go not only this he even gets inside the
car to accompany the fake ferment to the
abandoned warehouse unfortunately just
minutes later when the fake format puts
on the seat belt he comes in contact
with the poison and gets knocked
unconscious this results in a horrific
crash that kills both of them on the
spot back in the room hellbert finally
confesses the real reason why he has
done it all he reveals that he spent
decades working on the goldbach
conjecture but when he saw an article in
a magazine claiming that galwa a
bachelor had solved it before him he
felt like his life's work had been for
nothing Hilbert also reveals that he
once considered committing the
unthinkable but then decided to meet
galwa instead he states that when he
learned about galwa's presentation being
sabotaged he sent an email to him but it
was Olivia who replied confirming that
galwa had to redo everything Hilbert
then decided to set up a test to see how
intelligent galwa really was he
orchestrated the events of the evening
including putting poison in the clasp of
the fake Fermat's safety belt which
caused the car accident that killed him
along with the policeman
Albert's plan is to make the authorities
believe that the fake format has taken
revenge on Pascal as the group tries to
process this information galwa drops
another bombshell he never actually
solved the goldback conjecture he
reveals that he had lied about it to get
Olivia's attention and the LIE grew
until it gained media attention in
addition galwa also tells that he
destroyed his own presentation and lied
to the Press about it to keep up the
charade everyone knows that the goldbach
conjecture is the key to the female
orgasm and we all know that that's a
myth everyone is stunned by this
Revelation and the tension in the room
is palpable hearing all this Hilbert
realizes with a sense of relief that he
is the only one who has truly solved the
problem galwa then looks into Hilbert's
paperwork on the goldbock conjecture and
finds it to be absolutely amazing all of
a sudden he charges at Hilbert knocking
him out Pascal manages to stop him and
they all turn their attention to the
Blackboard where they see the word
libertad breaking it open they discover
an escape panel one by one they slide
into the opening hoping to escape this
treacherous room Olivia is the first to
go through and galwa follows her taking
Hilbert's paperwork on the goldbach
conjecture with him as the group escapes
through the panel Pascal finds himself
in a precarious situation where his
pants get caught almost trapping him in
the room but fortunately with a stroke
of luck he frees himself just in time
narrowly avoiding being crushed by the
closing presses in the last scene while
the trio is on a boat crossing the river
galwa Ponders whether he should publish
Hilbert's groundbreaking work on
goldbach conjecture under his own name
or attributed to Hell Barrett the movie
ends with Pascal stepping forward and
tossing the precious paperwork into the
flowing river sangawa doesn't deserve it
the world's not ready for the female
orgasm subscribe for more videos like
this turn on notifications and leave a
like to help the channel out thank you
for watching